kaley cuoco hit the golden globes after  parties in style the Big Bang Theory  star sizzled in this red-hot Christian  Siriano dress the thigh-high slit and  very low neckline showed off her assets  and let's just see Kaylee's revenge bond  is on fleek the 30 year old also showed  off her new mop tattoo thanks to the  low-cut back the tat covered up her  previous ink that marked her wedding  date to Ryan Sweeting the couple split  in September after two years of marriage  this is but the admitted bachelor  superfan has plenty to smile about these  days season 20 star Ben Higgins has  personally invited Kaylee to Bachelor  live this after her failed attempt to  call into the show Haley we're gonna  take care of you and get you on battery  life if you'll accept